welcome to New five-minute game yet okay
I'm opponent let's form okay i'm not
quite sure what's edible should choose
so he's going for for the c-4 g3 kind of
stuff so i'll go for a symmetrical setup
him the check would leave his a new
player all right um he's uh no he serves
100 something games almost like to check
once in awhile how many games those guys
have played so I've got a symmetrical
English um and I'm trying to set up kind
of reverse no Roxy bind here embassy 585
at some usually quite quite nice for
black but on this the reverse diversion
here on gal you need to be cautious
because this extra temple it's sometimes
really young really worth something yeah
I think this is even in theoretical
position I can go F sick so I can can
sacrifice the the pawn not sure okay
let's all play it safe don't don't
sacrifice upon you can also cancel i
think and then white can take on c6 95
and grab a pawn okay so if i cancel now
could be three supposed to soon
dangerous no it doesn't threaten to take
so i think i can castle yeah it's um in
for a quick F form yeah i think i need
to take yeah you can see them compared
to the normal maroc see kind of position
why does some
much more active here so what should I
do now it's not easy these pawns only 23
are possible weakness but i would need
to get some rooks on them to put some
pressure on these pawns and i've got all
my mind pieces on somewhat mediocre
positions c7 night especially I mean I
could try to get the night to deform but
this would weaken d5 I also can consider
Bishop be 695 as an idea and I think
I'll i tried this to to activate the PCM
i also wouldn't mind to exchange one or
two pieces here like 97 for Knight c3 or
something because some then I would have
my room in the center to put my rooks
there and it also would somehow a little
bit diminishes diminish the counter play
all right you just grab their
interesting yeah that's interesting plan
so if i take care i'm hopelessly week on
the light squares I don't think I want
to do this okay 27 and now we can yeah
yes more than one possibility you could
try you for or 93 but 93 looks I don't
know a little bit unnatural to me and if
I must consider that I can just take and
play that before try to win this pawn I
could even play night before immediately
also not bad at all
yeah I like the idea could take on these
seven now but this is just just terrible
ok so I'm attacking the 5 no 2 times
threatening to will upon him so we need
to react in some way now I'm not am
unsure maybe you should have taken and
then play now before now i could play
Knights e2 e3 here c43
I'm not sure what this move is doing
really okay okay if i retweeted a
special page 3 okay understand this now
but maybe we just struck the ATM look
the eight pressurizing d3 takes the
sixth I can recapture no problem and
then d3 is really weak yeah like that
Bishop f7 was was a problem on me at the
problem with this was Bishop h3 so I
cannot really move this Bishop only six
am I mean I can go to g4 bit this
doesn't do much oh this is um okay
doesn't this just I know it doesn't win
mature nobody does yeah sure yeah it's
just just the pin here on the Queen I
was first thinking Bishop 83 and I don't
know it's a bit just bogus I can move
the Queen pretty much anywhere with my
keys I resign yeah it just blundered to
PCM I think the position was Sam was
been anywhere understatement if you look
at this year it's um it's difficult to
see how wide should should cover his his
center here I mean how does he protect
you three take him but even here it's
difficult to protect the poem I mean
something like this I can do this here
and it's um it's looking grim yeah yeah
i think around here this was here let's
let's let's even get back one more move
all right here why it was certainly okay
he can do all kinds of plans say let's
say here it could go here and just
mobilize for them black shouldn't be a
bad in any way but so it's a normal
position for wide this year i'm not sure
about a variety i think black is already
quite quite fine and now we need to play
nazi you three definitely yeah computer
greece only move and this is so this is
bad now okay so thanks for thanks for
watching pretty short game here and i'll
start another one soon